herr höcker sie haben im vorfeld gesagt
ohne die afg soll in zukunft in
thüringen keine regierung mehr möglich
sein was machen sie jetzt mit ihren
glaub ich brauche von den politischen
spielregeln und der liegt jetzt in der
landschaft das ist gut für thüringen der
thüringer wähler hat uns mit einem
wahlergebnis beschenkt vor dem ich nur
in demut mein haupt nein kann dass ich
mal so deutlich sagen also über 100
prozent steigerung im verhältnis zu 2014
das gab es noch niemals in der landtags
geschichte thüringens und das zeigt wie
groß der druck der leidensdruck bei den
menschen ist die menschen wollen eine
neubelebung unserer demokratie sie
erleben die demokratie so habe ich das
im wahlkampf aus ganz vielen von ganz
vielen menschen gehört als erstarrt und
die altparteien sind gut beraten dieses
ergebnis wirklich sehr sehr genau
zurückdrehen
aber was heißt das konkret die
altparteien ich würde das in
anführungsstriche setzen sollen sich das
genau anschauen bis jetzt ist es ja so
niemand möchte mit ihnen koalieren
versuchen sie die cdu dazu überreden
doch noch mit ihnen zu sprechen
also ich sehe das als partei nicht in
anführungszeichen dieser termin ist es
vollkommen zielführend weil die
altparteien in den zentralen
politikfeldern ununterscheidbar geworden
sind deswegen sprach ich hatte von
weizsäcker schon anfang der 90er jahre
von einer staaten parteiendemokratie
die türen sind nicht mehr bereit diese
art von der starter parteiendemokratie
weiter zu tolerieren nochmal wir stehen
zu unserem wort wir sagen wir wollen
staatspolitische verantwortung tragen
sind eine bürgerlich patriotische kraft
in den letzten fünf jahren eine gute
parlamentarische arbeit in der
opposition gemacht hat und jetzt wollen
wir regieren
ein weiter so wird es nicht geben die
regierung ramelow ist vom thüringer
wähler abgewählt worden sie hat das
vertrauen entzogen bekommen und jetzt
muss thüringen neu aufgestellt
dem würde ich widersprechen wir die
zahlen anguckt herr ramelow die linke
hat ja nun mal die wahl auf jeden fall
gewonnen
die frage ist trotzdem noch mal haben
sie weiter hoffnung mit der cdu doch
noch ins gespräch zu kommen denn da gibt
es ja eigentlich ein sehr klares nein
naja die linke hat 15 prozent
hinzugewonnen da kann man glaube ich
nicht von einem wahlsieg reden das ist
vielleicht sagen wir mal
besitzstandswahrung wenn ich das mal so
beschreiben darf die cdu muss sich
entscheiden will sie weiter wie in den
letzten jahrzehnten dem rot grund bunten
zeit platz hinter herrschen oder will
sie zu ihren konservativen wurzeln
zurückkehren ich weiß dass im
landesverband der cdu
einige gibt die das genauso sehen die
sagen mit dem merkel ismus schaufeln wir
uns unser eigenes grab und ich sage der
cdu wenn ihr den weg so weitergeht in
den letzten jahrzehnten eingeschlagen
habe dann werdet ihr den weg der
italienischen christdemokratie gehen
dass der weg in die politische
bedeutungslosigkeit hacker eine frage
noch in ihrem wahlkampf da haben sie
immer wieder auf veranstaltungen die
wähler ihre zuhörer davor gewarnt
briefwahl zu machen
es gibt stand jetzt keine belege dazu
dass irgendwann bei briefwahl
das ist an manipulationen oder ähnliches
gegeben haben könnte warum machen sie so
was also erst mal haben wir leider in
den letzten jahren wiederholt
wahlmanipulationen gehabt vor kurzem
erst in brandenburg bei der landtagswahl
ist ja mittlerweile mittlerweile als
aufgeklärt und ja wir haben indizien
dafür dass das auch die briefwahl
ergebnisse für die afg zumindest eine
diskrepanz aufweisen zu den ergebnissen
die im wahllokal von den wählern
abgegeben was das für hintergründe hat
was das verursachen hat das wissen wir
selbst noch nicht genau aber für uns ist
es von daher auf der grundlage dessen
was wir wissen auf jeden fall sinnvoll
den wähler zu ermuntern direkt ins
wahllokal zu gehen ich will das gar
keine spekulationen jahren uns
irgendwelche spekulationen hier los
dreht ich möchte ihnen trotzdem sagen es
gibt ja sie sagen das ja es gibt
natürlich immer mal wieder bei 50.000
helfern kleine fehler die gemacht werden
alle fehler werden dann ja im nachhinein
haben sie gerade selber gesagt
aufgearbeitet dass da kann man ja nicht
von manipulationen sprechen haben sie
sie sie gefährden damit ja etwas das bei
uns in deutschland konsens ist nämlich
wir haben hier fähre freie wahlen
naja kleine fehler muss ich in
anführungszeichen setzen also was in
brandenburg gelaufen ist das waren keine
kleinen fehler mehr dass wir alles
aufgeklärt sind aber gravierende
eingriffe gewesen wirklicher und wir
sind ja gut beraten wenn wir sensibel
sind wenn wir einfach auch schauen dass
alles 100 prozent akkurat funktioniert
ich würde niemals von einer
flächendeckenden manipulation sprechen
um gottes willen aber es gibt einzelne
wahlhelfern einzelnen wahlbüros die in
den letzten jahren immer mal wieder
glaubten irgendwie eingreifen zu müssen
und das muss man einfach immer im
hinterkopf haben
danke hätte bis hierher